Hello, hello, BAU BAU!
It's time for... What?
It's time for... FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU!
It's official.
The morning is ruined, ruffians!
I'm not a chihuahua!
I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
And today, we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Yeah!
Ruffians, don't make that face!
Don't make that face!
Right now!
BAU BAU!
Thank you for joining us today for our 63rd episode!
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU!
Even though it's our 63rd episode, we still make mistakes, huh?
That's just life.
I was gonna say, I would hope, you know, maybe there's one or two Ruffians out there that maybe this is your first time watching FUWAMOCO Morning.
I'm sorry.
If this is your first time, I am sorry from the bottom of my heart!
I was gonna say, if it is your first time, well, FUWAMOCO Morning is a short-format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
A.K.A.
FUWAMOCO!
And it's hosted by us!
BAU BAU!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag.
Hashtag FWMCMORNING!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
It's your first time.
Apologies.
BAU BAU.
Well.
Even for Ruffians, it's not your first time.
We have some sad news.
There's been another Pero Sighting.
Where was he spotted this time?
Let's see.
Oh!
Uh, that would be a very nice view if it wasn't for that, uh, nasty blob out there.
Yeah!
Some interesting weather.
Yeah.
Uh, Pero, what are you doing?
Uh, why is he making a, uh, angry, silly, passionate face like that out there, huh?
Maybe... Does he feel left out that you're gonna go visit family without him?
Pero.
You're not a part of this Ruffians family, okay?
But... Maybe he just wants to spend the holidays together with someone.
Oh, true.
I guess, you know, he didn't really get that this year, huh?
In a way, we usually spend it all together in the cell and everything, right?
You know, this year, we've been a bit busy.
A bit busy, yeah.
Ruffians, what do you think?
Would you want Pero to be more of a part of our holidays in the future?
He's really big.
Would that be okay?
Pero and us and you.
Yeah.
No.
No?
He should stay out.
Valentine's Day too?
Valentine's!
He should stay out.
You wouldn't mind.
You want him to sing for karaoke parties?
You'd rather not, no?
Why?
I know, right?
Yes, let him in.
Maybe not Valentine's.
Valentine's with Pero would be nice.
I am questioning your decisions, Ruffians.
That's pretty nice, Ruffians.
Well, he is very nasty.
Maybe...
We'll have to think about it.
Maybe not.
But the ruffians are gonna be nice, Mococo-chan.
I think I've decided.
BAU BAU!
That's quite a sight to see while on the travels, you know?
Well, we have some... Some what?
Fun?
Good?
Some news!
News!
Some news?
To see ruffians!
There was something super exciting happen at the start of the year, right?
Right!
Our New Year Outfit Reveal!
BAU BAU!
They were supposed to happen on the first, right?
But they got postponed, huh?
But Ruffians, don't get too excited.
We want to still keep it in the front of your mind because we're hoping to have an update to you about it soon.
Soon, okay?
Soon!
Don't think that you can just take it easy and take a big breath of relief, okay, Ruffians?
Because you know, if you do so, you'll regret it when it comes to outfit reveals, okay?
Yeah, I know.
I want you to make sure, Ruffians, that you're going to make it still when you see them.
Very cute.
So please make sure that you look forward to all of Alphys' New Year outfits, okay?
You can breathe for now.
But we'll see.
BAU BAU!
There's been some more!
Happy New Year things.
Well, you know, this past weekend in Japan was Comike.
The biggest fan event in Japan.
And our Icomochi-mama was showing her first unofficial FUWAMOCO fanbook!
Really special.
You know there's a cute illustration book, acrylic stand, a blanket, and even these two cute FUWAMOCO guys!
They're there to hand out books and BAU BAU at you.
BAU BAU, the BAU BAUs are free.
Thank you so much to the Mashiro Sisters for helping Icomochi-mama with their booth.
You know what, Ruffians?
Thanks to everyone's enthusiasm, everything sold out there at the venue!
BAU BAU!
Icomochi-mama even did an extra print run of the books to sell online!
And even those sold out very, very quickly!
Congratulations, Icomochi-mama!
We're so happy!
BAU BAU!
We hope that there will be even more FUWAMOCO Doujinshi in the future.
Update on our side.
Yes, Mane-chan was able to get us our goods.
We're looking forward to them!
BAU BAU!
Good news, hai.
Good news.
We also have more happy news.
I know we mentioned it earlier before the New Year, but we saw something amazing made by the Ruffians.
Message music for the New Year!
BAU BAU!
Ruffians, you worked all together to make it!
We're so happy!
We wanted to take our time to look over it well.
So it took us a bit of time.
Yeah, it has a bunch of heartwarming messages on it.
New Year's Resolutions from so many Ruffians!
Some of them, very, very good resolutions.
Some of them.
I don't know if I can agree with them as much as some others, but
All I can say is, good luck!
You know, the music and the art, everything is so great!
I was listening to the music the whole time!
Please check it out, Ruffians!
You can find it at FUWAMOCONEWYEARS.DE!
If you have a moment...
Ruffians!
Let's work hard all together to make ourselves stronger and grow even more in 2024.
Got it!
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
BAU
Well, it has been a little while since we last did something like this.
It's been busy.
Yeah, it's not because we forgot.
No, just like Moco-chan said, it's because it's been especially busy recently.
But you know what?
It's a new year!
And so we thought we'd bring it back!
So!
This Thursday at 8pm PT or 1pm JST, we're going to be holding another Morning Response on Twitter!
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU!
It's on at...
Thursday the 4th at 8pm ET.
If you're not sure what a RR and response is, it's very simple.
For a certain period of time, we'll do our all to respond to your tweets.
We can't respond to every Ruffian's tweets, but we'll do everything we can to respond to as many as we can.
We'll put out a tweet about the wrong response, and if you respond to that and use the hashtag FUWAMOCO in your tweet, we'll do our best to respond!
Yeah, you know, which ruffians we respond to is always completely random, but we do hope that we'll be able to send you a tweet back.
Yeah, we'll be doing it for an hour and a half until 9.30pm PT.
Are you excited, Ruffians?
BAU BAU!
What is a Twitter?
A Twitter is a Twitter and a Twitter is a tweet.
It's a little boring.
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
There's some more interesting news going on!
There was something announced the other day.
Together in partnership with Capsule, there's going to be a new hololive collab cafe happening in Taiwan City!
BAU BAU!
It's CHEER UP Cafe!
From January 27th to February 4th, you can see Subaru-senpai, and Pekora-senpai, Kobo-senpai, Kaira-senpai, Kura-senpai, and Alvin's Biboo!
Biboo!
Wearing these super super duper cute cheer outfits and get themed food and all that fun stuff.
Why, it looks super cute and colorful!
You know, Biboo looks extra cute in her cheer outfit too.
You know, I would like to wear this super cute cheer outfit too.
Huh?
Moco-chan, you feeling a little envious?
No.
Don't you think you'll be good for Pup Talk soon?
Huh?
Yeah, whatever Mococo, hi.
But you know Biboo, she looks so happy and sparkly.
And she has the little biboo biboo biboo.
Right.
Yeah, Pebbles definitely won't want to miss out on the merch from the collab cafe.
Make sure you mark it in your calendar, okay?
Yeah, and maybe share with FUWAMOCO too.
Wait, I want words too!
It's so cute!
Not fair.
BAU BAU!
I'm happy.
It cheered you up already?
Yes.
It hasn't even started yet.
BAU BAU!
Ruffians.
Um... I have something to say.
Is it a Pup Talk?
No.
I have a confession to make.
Hehehe... Yeah.
Ruffians!
So, you know, right?
Usually, I'll tweet about our next upcoming stream right before I go to bed, right?
And a lot of times, by that point, Moco-chan is long past that.
Not a lot of times, just last night.
I don't know.
Just last night.
So, I did my best all on my own, but sometimes, you know,
I write to stay awake and you know, I have to write the tweet in a way that doesn't sound like in the vlog!
I'm half awake when writing it.
Yesterday's FUWAMOCO Morning Tweet, it was particularly rough.
The tweet for today.
Don't go and analyze it, okay, Ruffians?
As I was writing it, I kept on falling asleep and forgetting what I was going to write.
You know, it was strange because I kept on hearing Nerissa laughing.
I wake up to her laughing.
What?
You know, Nerissa being like... What?
That sound like her?
Don't look at me.
Do you know what I mean, Ruffians?
I don't know why, but every time I hear her laughing, I wake up, I write a little more of the tweet, then I fall asleep.
Then I hear Nerissa and repeat and repeat and repeat until I finally finish the tweet.
And then I fell asleep for good.
It was weird.
I don't know.
That's good.
I wonder why.
It went down in the end, so that's good.
Wait, am I okay?
Am I okay?
I don't know.
Just, Norris is not leaving my brain, huh?
Whatever, Mococo.
Huh?
What do you mean, Moco-chan?
Why is Norris in your brain so much, huh?
Is it because you keep on DMing or what?
We're talking about girl stuff, right?
I don't know, Ruffians.
Maybe this is a sign not to tweet right before bed.
Oops.
BAU BAU!
It was weird.
I just kept on hearing the wrists laughing.
I wonder what she was laughing about.
That's weird.
Weird things happening from the very beginning of the year, huh?
Well... I thought maybe... I'd say something.
But is it okay?
Because it's not weird.
Do you still want to hear it if it's not weird, Ruffians?
I don't know, Moco-chan.
I don't see any cheer output from you.
I'm making a sour face.
I want a Doggie of the Day.
Oh, the Doggie of the Day!
Doggie of the Day is not Moco-chan!
It's never me.
No, Moco-chan, the Doggie of the Day isn't supposed to be us.
You want a pup talk?
I think, Moco-chan, we need a pup talk.
The year's beginning and maybe it's a little rough.
Well!
RUFFIANS!
I have something to tell you.
And, you know what?
You're gonna want to listen to what I have to say, okay?
You know what this is.
You should know, cause I already said what it is.
This here is a Mococo Pup Talk!
And you're gonna hear straight from me.
Mococo!
You.
Ruffian!
Did you know?
It's officially 2024!
It's the new year!
Can you believe it?
Somehow, you know, we all get to live in the same time together!
It's sort of amazing when you think about it, huh?
Well!
Have you been thinking about your New Year resolution?
You know, I know a lot of you have one or two.
And some of you, you have many!
And you know what?
That's great!
But... The most important thing is...
You know, just continue at your New Year's resolution.
I think it's easy to get down and be hard on yourself when maybe a week goes by and you realize, oh, I wasn't able to work on my goal at all!
So, don't beat yourself up over those sort of things, okay?
It happens to all of us!
Sometimes you're busy, you're tired, you can't balance it all all the time.
Even one step forward a week is 50 steps a year!
You'll get somewhere better than before, okay?
The most important thing is to just continue at it!
Because if you stop and you give up, it's over.
Nothing will change.
And I know change can be scary, but sometimes no change is even more frightening.
I know you can do it.
Just pace yourself.
And you know what?
I'll be here to have your back, okay?
We can do it all together!
Ganbatte de!
BAU BAU!
Let's do our best once again, FUWAMOCO Ruffians!
Next, we have our Doggie of the Day!
Today's Doggie of the Day is... Haru!
BAU BAU!
Very dressed up, huh?
Haru's a cutie!
You know, I'm not a dragon, I'm a chihuahua!
I'm not a dragon, I'm a chihuahua!
Cute!
Well, Haru has an appetite like a dragon, but only weighs 5 kg.
Tiny dragon.
Yeah, he's not a fan of walks either.
He likes to get babied and be carried around too.
Maybe sometimes.
Moco-chan you like that!
Princess Kyori is mine.
You'll do the same thing as Haru though.
Get carried halfway and then walk away home.
I'm a princess!
I'm Mococo!
BAU BAU!
How does Haru BAU BAU?
Like a tiny dragon.
You have to imagine you sort of spit fire a bit.
BAU BAU!
Tiny Fireball.
Sounds like a ray gun.
That's basically what Haru is.
Haru is basically a ray gun.
A baby ray gun.
As you can all see, Haru is very excited about the new year.
The year of the dragon.
Even if Haru is tiny,
There's a dragon inside!
Inside the heart!
And outside the heart!
Haru's New Year's resolution is to eat lots of yummy food and also get lots of cuddles from his special ruffians.
That sounds nice.
BAU BAU!
Bye!
Very cute.
Haru's just like a dragon.
What kind of walk so Ruffians have been going on?
Today's walk is... De-den!
Pretty!
What a snowy.
Was this the first time you got to see the snow this year?
It is a new year.
Not the first time ever, was it?
Just the first time this year.
You know, the snow on the ground and the clear blue skies.
Nothing really beats a high.
Except for the sun.
And the snowman there!
Super cute.
Very cute.
Good job.
We're glad you had an awesome hike!
BAU BAU!
Up next, our Question of the Day.
We have De-den!
FUWAMOCO!
I have a question.
BAU BAU!
During your walk in my streams, do you hold back an explicit urge to return to your native tongue every lyric into a BAU BAU?
This is a good question.
I could feel that urge coming from my side.
You could tell.
How did you know it is?
But, but, but, we can't.
Because, you know, it'd be a little rude to the creators who work very hard to make meaningful lyrics in English or Japanese.
It's their lyrics, you know.
Although, you know, we sing them with a lot of heart when we say BAU BAU instead.
But...
Maybe just sometimes.
Yeah, but we do sometimes.
Here and there, you know, when we can.
But not too much.
Not too much.
We pull ourselves back, okay?
BAU BAU!
Thank you, Ruffians!
Thank you so much for all your Doggie of the Day questions!
Such good questions, always.
Your walks and...
Pero Sightings too.
And also, especially the friend, FUWAMOCO Scoop.
It's really been helping us a lot.
Thank you for your great journalism, Ruffians!
And please don't forget to use the hashtag, hashtag FWMCMORNING and hashtag FWMCScoop for your scoops!
BAU BAU!
And as for our next stream!
Well, today we're playing...
Super Mario Bros.
Live!
And the last time we were playing, it got pretty intense.
Yeah, but today, you know, we're gonna do our best to play nicely as a team together.
Yeah!
We'll do our best, okay?
BAU BAU!
And if we take another peek at our schedule, here we are!
Well, Thursday is going to be a little bit of a homework day for us, but we also have a ramen response, so please
As for the rest of our schedule, you might know there might be some more changes coming up, so please do keep an eye on our Twitter and YouTube community page.
But one thing that won't be changing for sure is the holocaust.
The Big Mario Kart Tenement.
We're gonna do our best, okay, Ruffians?
Please cheer for us.
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for joining us today for another episode of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Before we say BAU BAU, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Texi!
BAU BAU!
Rokumura!
Fima!
BAU BAU!
Starry Sark.
Pond.
BAU BAU!
First Time Ruffian.
JM.
BAU BAU!
Sell Me.
You.
BAU BAU!
Figure of Live.
And to every other ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!